if the pandemic wiped out your travel  plans be sure to read the fine print on  any vouchers or credits you may have  received  travel experts say it is important to  check for travel by deadlines on those  documents  some airlines have been flexible on  trying to extend those dates so  it may also be a good idea to buy now if  you're looking to travel later this year  closer to summer months vaccinations  become higher and cases hopefully drop  we can expect prices to increase  if you decide to change your booking  down the road and the flight's actually  cheaper  try and ask your airline for a travel  credit for the difference  they may say yes